- And I see exactly what
you fucking ask him.
Let me give you the fucking answer.
This guy fucking worked.
- For sure.
- [Gary] Fucking ate dirt.
- Was patient as fuck.
- [Da Baby] Yeah.
So if you want it go fucking do it.
- [Da Baby] Stupid ass.
(laughing)
- Stupid ass.
- [Gary] Based on my thesis
that hip-hop rules the world,
it's probably a 50 billion
dollar company if you--
- What's your thesis?
- Hip-Hop rules the world.
- Fucking with you bro.
(imitates ringing noise)
♪ Moving in quick ♪
♪ Trying to get rich and
I'm dodgin' these dicks ♪
♪ Got head in the Uber
the called me a Lyft ♪
♪ She pissed but it is
what it is what it is ♪
♪ Girl I'm stuck up in my ways, yeah ♪
♪ Get the fuck outta my flex ♪
♪ Then I need ya, let's go ♪
♪ I fuck with you like
Martin fuck with Gina ♪
♪ We family like we
Venus and Serena, hey ♪
♪ Let's go get married like we
thank God and Kanisha, okay ♪
♪ Don't give a fuck about the
world, just bout my people ♪
♪ I don't care what the fuck
they told you, we ain't equal ♪
♪ Niggas ain't cut from the same cloth ♪
♪ These niggas see-through ♪
- When did you guy kind of know
that this was going to be that moment?
Like is there just like a funny moment?
I always find it interesting
when somebody gets that white hot.
Like, somebody sharing it.
Obviously it's all now all just momentum
Like what moment in the last
nine months were you like,
"Oh."
Was there anything like that?
- Probably when I started the tour,
I dropped Suge and we started a tour.
We dropped a Suge video of my tour
and I just seen how it was like real fans,
all ticket venues, you know what I mean?
That alone with the success--
- Selling out,
- knowing the words.
- [Da Baby] Yeah.
- And with the success of the song,
it was dope, you know what I mean?
Kept writing.
And I was all the way
over, like I don't even--
you know.
Because even now, I don't
get complacent personally.
I don't got no moment like,
where I feel like, you know,
moments where I feel like
where I'm sitting here saying,
yeah that was probably the turning point.
In them moments I wasn't
ecstatic at all you feel me?
Like I had a straight
face, you know what I mean.
- What about when you beat
up the dude in the mall?
- What about it?
(both laughing)
- I'm just kidding, I was laughing.
That was super entertaining that Sunday.
- We got back to work and went
and did a show that night.
- [Gary] That was super entertaining.
- Went and did a show that night.
- How hard are you going on TikTok?
- I don't even use TikTok.
I use the, is that
- [Gary] Bro I'm telling you
the same thing as Triller,
is it like Triller?
- It is but the difference
is like doing a track
with Beyonce versus Shmeyonce.
- Like so, it's the same thing?
- I want every nine-year-old
in America to fuck with you.
- [Da Baby] TikTok?
- And you can make that happen on TikTok
in the next 30 days.
- [Da Baby] Okay, I'm
going to download it.
- You need to.
- [Man] I would say it's
mainly right now we focus
so heavily on IG and YouTube.
- Yeah.
- [Man] And the
conversation of getting into
Facebook and those other platforms--
- I think knowing him for sure, for sure
TikTok and Twitter you
need to really consider.
- Man, let me in on my damn phone man.
- [Man] He has a Twitter he just--
- I just don't need
love, I keep bullshitting
- [Gary] TikTok is a must
because TikTok is where music like,
TikTok is a must.
Honestly, I'm going to
lock you in this room
until you guys like,
And I'll probably lose that fight.
- I'm going to download it right now.
Everybody says that they think
when I do Triller that that is TikTok.
- [Gary] You're going
to get so many free fans
every day on TikTok.
And that's what you want.
- [Mike] Your songs are
probably already going viral
on that so if you jumped
on it'd just magnify it.
- TikTok is requirement.
TikTok is the only app on Earth
that has the chance to
become the next Instagram.
If it continues to get older
and they make some other changes.
And they add pictures.
If TikTok tomorrow adds pictures
the way that Instagram added stories,
it can get real interesting
there real fast.
So TikTok for sure.
Twitter, I just think your personality
would dominate on Twitter.
I think you just jumping into
people talking about you.
Like giving love or razzing or whatever.
You just, from what I see from you,
your improv nature as
an artist strikes me.
Its why I think you,
like SNL is probably real close for you.
And like I think of you more like JT.
Like I think you can do SNL as both.
Like I want to see you in a skit.
- [Da Baby] For sure.
- You're funny.
- Well you do some shit, like
I could do a lot of that now.
I just don't want to.
- Star power is star power.
There's a lot of people I like.
People come through here I like
because I really like them
as a as a musical talent
and then there's people
that are just superstars.
You're going to be a superstar, bro.
- [Da Baby] Appreciate you bro.
- It's super obvious to me.
- [Da Baby] Appreciate it.
- I took a screenshot the other day
of the first time I hit you up
because in two years I want
to be like this is what I do.
- For sure.
- Let me give you another big insight
that I think will go crazy for you guys.
Access.
The number one thing that
people want is access.
The amount of fucking people
that if they knew this meeting
was happening right now,
that would rip their arm off
just to be just sitting in this room.
- Oh for sure.
People want access.
So I think one of the things
that like for example,
him doing something that
creates a winner each day
to do a three-minute FaceTime with him.
- Yeah we used to do
that shit all the time.
That goes so crazy.
This was years ago.
- You know what's so great
about Hip Hop for me,
and just watching how you answer that?
All my moves,
they're 1987 Hip Hop moves.
It's just selling shit from
the back of your trunk.
- For sure.
It's stickers.
It's tapping people in
Times Square saying,
"Yo yo yo before you go let
me give you this free CD.
"Oh wait you gotta pay me or
I'll punch you in the mouth."
Like you know,
it's just the same shit.
It's the hotline, Mike Jones.
Mike Jones put out his phone number
it's the same shit I'm doing right now.
That honestly, one of the best
things about all this for me
is I wish I had musical talent
I would drop a song right now
that was literally my cell phone number
for two minutes and 13
seconds against a hot beat.
And I'd have the biggest--
If he dropped a song right now
with his community phone number.
- Bro, that shit would crash.
- [Gary] He'd have four million fucking,
he'd have four, five, seven
million fans on a database
and he can make anything happen.
Five hundred dollar
limited edition hoodie.
Five thousand units sold out one second.
Have 800,000
have 80,000 people show up right now
in the middle of Manhattan in an hour
to have the news cover it, boom.
You need to get on Community,
I'm gonna get you on.
and you need to put out a song
with a fucking number on it.
- [Da Baby] Watch this.
- I believe you and I'm going to be happy
because you'll be the
number one person with it.
It'll work, I'm going to
make that happen ASAP.
We got to talk to Andy tomorrow,
they gave me like a bunch
of slots to give out.
- [Mike] I'm going to be in that meeting.
- You are going to be in that
morning meeting tomorrow?
That is the one, that's the
fucking, that's the moment.
Him, on that platform,
and I actually believe he's
going to execute and do the song
and it's game over.
He's going to have four fucking million.
And straight up just like you remember,
it was just five seconds ago.
Fucking how much money do
you think fucking Khaled made
because of that one
Snapchat fucking summer?
At this point it's gotta be 50 to 100.
There's a way to replicate that moment.
At that moment what it was,
was people didn't realize
how big Snapchat was,
he became the guy and his ability be like,
"Yo, meet me here."
And then we saw the crowds, right?
And then we're just like, damn.
I think you can replicate that.
You do the Community thing,
you have all the cell numbers.
And then you come out in six months,
you know, take you some time,
I don't know what your timing is.
And then all of a sudden
four months you're like,
"Watch this.
"Yo Memphis, I'm going to be
on this street in an hour."
And you'll have fuckin'
15,000 people there.
- That sounds scary.
(all laughing) And they want
me to be able to do that.
- [Gary] And that's how you
win, that's how people are like,
"Yo this is different."
- I can do that now.
- [Gary] You can, but
if you get cell numbers.
Let me tell you how I know.
If I posted on Instagram
with my 6.8 million
followers right now and said,
"Yo use this hashtag on Twitter
to win a dinner with me."
Or I send it to my 115,000
text phone numbers,
it's not even close.
First of all, you know this,
the algorithm doesn't show
it to 90% of the people.
Let's start with that.
Second, people like this.
When you get a fuckin' text,
and the way they do it is smart.
It's a platform right,
I'll show it to you.
so it's a platform and
so like on the backend
I see it like a DM, you know?
Right like, "Hey Gary."
And I'm like, yo what's good Alex, right?
He gets this as a text.
And when he signed up,
he got my contact card,
so he locked me in.
So now if you do that,
you know how it is.
If you're sitting right
now with your friends
and you get a text and it's
from the contact DaBaby
and it's like, right?
That's crazy.
- Lose their fucking mind.
- I always say the same shit I'm like,
yo when I was a kid Macho
Man Randy Savage had this,
and he texted me I
would have lost my mind.
- [Man] And it's invite only.
- And I saw one of you
sent them like voice memos
so they knew it was you type shit.
So you don't got to get
as personal as a FaceTime.
- My man, you've been
impressing me this whole time,
that little spot.
You keep watching people
that know what the fuck they're doing,
you'll be unstoppable.
- I don't watch nobody that
don't know what they're doing.
I even like when they come
in like, merch and shit.
Like if I put my focus
on selling this hoodie
or this whatever.
I put my focus on selling like,
I'm gonna sell it.
So I don't want to put too much in.
Whatever I tell people to
that's where they going to go.
It just go like that,
you get what I'm saying.
I want to make sure that whatever I do,
that it don't get in the
way of what the primary,
the workhorse.
- You're so young.
You get what I'm saying?
- 100%, of course I do.
That's how that is.
Like whatever I do,
got to be able to coexist
with what I got going on.
And help it, you know what I mean?
And that's why I lean
towards doing some shit,
but I kind of just feel the universe out
- [Gary] Bro, I'm the same as that.
The amount of times I got
to third-and-a-half base,
everyone's excited, and
I just wake up I'm like
"We're not doing that."
and everyone's like, "Why?"
And I'm like,
"Because I don't think
it's going to be right."
- Motherfuckers look at
me crazy all the time.
- [Gary] Actually you want
to hear something your world?
Mike and I,
this a great story, Mike and I
decided last, not this last
summer, the last summer,
we decided we would just meet
with so many people in music.
Well that's what we were
really doing meetings
like every third day.
- Like last winter really
cause Tier dropped in May
so before that.
- I met, two Memorial days
ago so like not last May
before right and the winter before that
I was gonna drop a mixtape
but like produce it just like put together
people that I really fucked with
and tell stories that I really believed in
and it was gonna come
out during Memorial Day
and the thematic was, you're
all about to get fucking soft
in the summer and drink your fucking Rosé
and chill by the pool
and I'm about to triple the fuck down,
see you in September.
Right, so it's basically
like an anthem of like
I know everyone's about to
kind of go cool in the summer
I'm about to triple the fuck down
the first fuck-- so we
made a bunch of track
we had I mean Rallo came
through like we had fuckin
like like we made a Tierra Whack,
Tee Grizzley, Gunna track.
Two years ago.
Fire.
Like it was, we were putting together
some real, we were doing some fun shit
what was it young bands
and Trinidad James?
Like we were doing some real fun shit
with like people I fucked with
and it was going and like real
we had some other crazy shit lined up
and I just called him one day
I'm like, I don't want to put it out
we just thought a complete, like,
it felt perfect like the game changer
and then the next morning it felt like
it's 1% off and I mean,
I don't like 1% off to begin with
1% off in hip hop or
the culture it's game.
- [Da Baby] That can blow it.
- [Gary] Game over.
It's fun to have those songs though
- [Man] Yeah, they're great songs.
(mumbles)
- Yeah man, we fuckin',
Richie South like what a--
it was some fucking good shit.
Honestly bro, right now,
you need to put out as
much content as possible.
You're fuckin',
there's so few people
that get this hot ever,
you got to recognize it.
You're so in it, you're
like in the eye of the storm
but like, you agree with me right?
- [Man] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're unbelievably hot.
- For real.
- [Man] Like Lizzo track
and people don't do that.
- Yeah right for sure, for sure.
- That iPhone song is real fucking legit.
- [Da Baby] I made that
song like two years ago.
- Yeah you did a bunch of
these in hotel rooms right?
- Yeah, for sure.
He engineered it.
- [Gary] Fucking dirt, I fucking love it
- DJ, engineer, he produce.
- People are always like, you know this,
you've seen this, people are always like,
"Yeah I already booked equipment."
I'm like motherfucker,
do you understand that Novak Djokovic
could take a fucking
wooden racket from 1847
and beat your fucking ass
in tennis in two minutes
if you had all the best
fucking new Nike this,
and fucking graphite that.
Like this ain't a fucking,
I mean obviously you need basic equipment
to like pull something off but like
this is talent.
By the way,
and the thing you have to
do for the other artists
is you got to put them in a position
you see he's natural improv comedic timing
he's got a lot of weird shit going on
like in a great way, which is amazing!
Not everybody-- what your
job to do for everybody,
everyone's gonna be different,
as they come on you got to figure out
what they're naturally at.
like one of them needs to
have a podcast and a guest
And that's where all the
contents gonna come from.
so make sure that you realize how to,
you know, mix up the blueprint
predicated on their DNA
- And that's what I be
try to do when I come
to him like, I be wantin'--
I want him to flourish in his own world,
you get what I'm saying?
- [Gary] A hundred percent.
- Because he--
- [Gary] It's the only way.
- got all this shit going too. You know,
a lot of the shit he randomly
do it's funny as fuck.
He fun as hell to be around too.
It's just, it gets shown
in a different way.
- Of course, of course it's
just the way it should be.
- You come up to him like,
boom, like this it ain't, you know.
- [Gary] That's not what
it's gonna be about.
- Watch out, you know I mean?
So is just that.
- There's just all different ways.
What about video games?
- Video games, I definitely
do some shit like that too.
- Because I think you could--
- The ideas I would do with it,
I would do like some
Grand Theft Auto type shit
and wouldn't give a fuck.
Twitch could be huge for you.
- [Da Baby] Twitch, what's that?
- Twitch is the platform
where kids play video games competitively
or people watch people play video games.
It's fucking huge.
- [Da Baby] That'd be dope.
And people like watch me
playing Grand Theft Auto?
- [Man] It's like a live stream?
- [Da Baby] It's just whatever
game I want to play, yeah?
- Yeah and people watch you.
- [Da Baby] Yeah, yeah,
yeah, that'd go crazy.
- I'm thinking about places where--
How do you become worldwide?
If you're playing on Twitch
and you become part of the community
and now people fuck with your music,
that's how you get an
email from China saying,
"Yo we want you to play
"and here's a number you
haven't seen before in America."
And you're all looking at each other
and you're like, fucking
Gary Vee and Twitch.
Like that that's what this means, right?
I'm trying to think about
how to bring value for you.
America is a foregone conclusion.
Now you gotta start thinking about global.
- [Da Baby] For sure.
- And video games and Twitch,
I think gives you a chance to win Asia
and Asia is interesting.
Japan and pick up some more babe shit
and like you know, you
could do some real shit.
It's something to think about.
TikTok too because it's
a Chinese based company
and its global.
I can't push enough on TikTok.
- [Da Baby] I downloaded it.
(talking over each other)
- Yeah Community you
have to get invited into.
We'll take care of that, we'll hit you up.
TikTok ASAP.
- [Man] You think it's worth
fucking with the IGTV shit
and focusing on that at all?
I see you do it.
Like you post like longer
pieces like minute and a half.
- 'Cause we're making so much long--
these guys fucking filming me
for 15 hours straight a day.
We have so much content
so I'm not against it
and we knew for a while
that if you made an IGTV
instead of a regular IG
it would get more views.
IG right now, for us,
is going is going through
the first time of decline
like all the personalities are declining.
And I think we might be
in that first moment,
that I've been telling--
No IG's doing great!
It's just that people are
pumping so much money into IG,
advertisers, that organic
reach is gonna decline.
Just like Facebook.
- [Man] I was like getting
curious about the app,
the phone version of YouTube
like the community now
and the stories like it's
still not as good as it what
IG is but I see them trying
to do something like that
so I'm curious about--
- They could.
Like all of a sudden I
give a fuck about LinkedIn,
out of nowhere, like shit can happen.
Again, like Twitter could
start stories tomorrow.
Anything can happen about anything.
Like this is where people aren't smart.
They're like, oh like this
is corny now I'm not on it.
I'm like cool I'll just still be on it
because tomorrow they may do something
that's becomes the fliest shit
and then you wanna be on it.
By the way that is TikTok,
it was called fucking
Musically two years ago.
- [Man] For real?
- Yeah.
TikTok bought Musically.
- [Da Baby] That shit was poppin'.
TikTok bought Musically, got it?
And really what are they?
It's fucking Vine.
It's what it really is with music,
with just a lot of music.
But real hit songs are
coming out of TikTok.
Like real, like Lil Nas X is 100% that.
And that's the preview, that's
not an anomaly, a lucky thing
like you've got, it's the
number one app in the App Store,
it's data.
Numbers don't lie.
You know?
For sure.
- I got it downloaded.
- [Gary] Yeah, Twitter too
Twitter you'll get real good at real fast.
You're just funny I just think
I think people who follow you on twitter
because I think you would be great at
jumping into people talking about you
- [Da Baby] Exactly.
- Uh-huh I just could
see you doing funny shit
and then people just followed you
to see what the fuck, yeah exactly.
Twitter's good.
It's not the place you push it out
like, you don't get the
kind of numbers you get
and that's why I do
people don't fuck with it
but it's the one place where,
somebody ridiculous left field might.
I mean so I just posted,
like I shared his song and I
look at all these funny people
they're like giving him love
and they don't look like
the people who like,
we're funny with our playlists
because we're getting people
listen to music that would,
I mean it's crazy.
I have like, 53 year old
white accountants in Iowa
who know about fuckin' the streets
they're like our music so early
like they've been listening to
Keed for two years, you know?
They're like 54, like you know,
it's just crazy what,
what happens with us.
Plus so many A&R guys are watching us
but but it's funny to see what people say
and then I'm just thinking
about him jumping in
and engaging with that kind of content
or the actress of the moment
gives him love on Twitter
he jumps in and he says, yo what's up?
Like just shit that
people will catch on to.
You see where I'm going?
You can't do that.
Some actress leaves a comment on his post
and he replies on Instagram
and does that thing.
That's just Instagram and nobody--
you do that on Twitter,
and like all the publication's
pick it up and retweet it
and becomes news, got it?
Selena Gomez being like, "Oh
you that's a great song."
and you'd be like, yo what's up.
you know like that's Instagram
'cause it's a fuckin' dating app.
But on Twitter that's on fuckin'
E fuckin' News that night.
See where I'm going?
And it's all the same shit
you that comes natural to you.
It's just one big game of
stickers on a fucking tree.
That's why Twitter.
Got it?
That's not the place you talk
That's a place you
respond to create smoke.
So you're just looking at
people who are mentioning you
and you're like yo that's funny, like,
that's my favorite football
player or like, you know?
Like Jalen Ramsey's just
tweeting like, "This is fire."
And you're like, yeah what's up, you know?
Cam Newton you're like,
yo my city, feel better.
It's where you talk.
- Win a damn game.
Say some shit, that shit go viral.
I just tweeted, who wants
Da Baby To start tweeting?
I know this odd kinda shit
I want to fuck with them tonight too.
I been meaning to do that but I just be.
- You're busy and you know
what happens to everybody?
they fucking triple down on what works.
So the Gram's working right
and everyone gets one dimensional.
That's why people lost.
Like Tila Tequila should have
done Facebook and Twitter.
But she thought MySpace was forever.
(laughing)
Seriously.
But like you know exactly
what I'm talking about
like people get stuck on the
thing that got them there
if you're not innovating
you're fucking dying.
- [Da Baby] For sure that.
- So that's what I would say.
And there's always something and access.
You seem so fun.
Access for everybody even
the most boring celebrity,
people want access to.
I'm telling you,
you do a contest that
gives somebody every day
a two minute FaceTime?
You can use that as leverage
to make whatever the
fuck you want to happen.
If you would have dropped some shit like,
yo, for everybody that puts
this in their Instagram story,
today's the day the
fuckin'(mumbles) drops,
I'm gonna pick two of you
and FaceTime with you.
You would have had fucking
500,000 more people
putting in their stories
which would have led to
750,000 more people find
out who the fuck you are
so the gamification of the
amplification around access.
- What type of apps y'all
use for the phone shit?
- [Gary] The Community thing?
- That's what it's called?
- [Gary] It's called Community.
But it's closed right now
because they gotta get approved by the,
it goes through the pipes.
You gotta get approved by Verizon
and AT&T.
- [Da Baby] How they price that stuff?
- It's all set, I got you.
Like, I'll get you set up,
I'll hook you up with the
people that are running it
we've been testing it
for about two months now
it's fuckin' the most--
This is the most powerful shit
I've seen since early email.
You guys are youngsters,
but when I started doing email in 1999
95% of people looked at their email.
Like, you got an email
you fuckin' read it.
- Yeah, shit I remember
I used to be like that
a little bit on.
- [Gary] You know.
- [Da Baby] I fuckin' hate email now.
- It's texts.
It's text, you're gonna
look at your texts.
- It may say well Microsoft
Messenger and some shit.
- I'm going on Instagram Live,
I'm getting people fuckin' hype, fuck it.
- [Da Baby] They gonna go crazy.
- They're about to
fucking lose their mind.
- [Man] We could just go live together.
Where you at Gary?
- [Da Baby] Turn the camera around.
That shit gonna start echoing man.
(talking overlapping)
- What up Gram, what up Gram?
What up Paul?
Mike Boy, what's good, tell them.
Boy, you look good man.
I like your fucking haircut.
I like what you did.
- Thanks a lot.
- You're welcome.
Yo Gram,
if you don't know,
you need to know what
I'm about to show you.
tell him Baby.
- [Da Baby] Come on man.
Number one album in the world.
- [Gary] Fuck man, I really
want to say that one day.
- The best motherfucking
rapper in the world man
- [Gary] Tell 'em, tell 'em.
You've been seeing me push it.
- You n****s is in trouble
I'm here with Gary Vee
you in fucking trouble long story short.
- [Gary] It's over now it's over now.
- He's teaching me shit
that he shouldn't have fucking taught me.
- [Gary] And now it's gonna get ugly.
- [Da Baby] Right I don't
even got no-- you in trouble.
- When you get the blueprint,
now you just gotta execute it.
- [Da Baby] Gonna go down,
Go ahead, take it over.
- What's fucking good?
(laughing)
Number one.
- [Da Baby] Number one.
Number one album in the
motherfucking world, man.
- Yo this man fucking
made this shit happen.
I fucking see him go live
I'm gonna jump in there
with all fuckin 12,000 of you too
and I see exactly what
you fuckin' asked him
let me give you the fucking answer.
This guy fucking worked.
Fucking eat dirt.
Was patient as fuck.
So if you want to go fucking do it.
- [Man 2] Stupid ass.
(laughing)
- Stupid ass.
- [Man 3] Fuck wrong with you?
Bro you're so dangerously close.
I think you may have--
I think you guys may
really think about doing TV
like movies.
Yeah you guys need to have a real play,
like how are you thinking about it?
Like have you started
talking like real Holly--
like have you talked to CAA?
- They aint ready for that.
They ain't ready for that.
I'm like, what the fuck we waiting on?
You know, I know it need to happen now.
- You know what I been
thinking a lot about?
What would it look like if you went
and did like you and Dave Chappelle
and you know rest in peace,
like me and Nipsey spent,
actually it's crazy,
last time I saw Nip was in Charlotte
with dinner at an MBA
and we were talking a
lot about this idea of
what would it look like if
you brought like Rolling Loud
and TED talk you know?
- [Da Baby] What's TED Talk?
- TED talk was like all
those big thoughtful talks
there's a conference in Vancouver
real heavy shit like
you know talking about
like just real serious
shit, like serious keynotes.
And you know Nip was super thoughtful
so like we would talk about a lot
I feel like there's an arena
or I feel like there's an event to be made
where like honestly where like,
I come out and give a keynote
and then you're the next person out
and you fucking shred that stage
and the next person is like Mark Cuban
talking about like sports business
and then fucking The Stallion comes out
and she fucking kills it
like literally just going like, you know?
I think that's where the culture is like
kids like you never were
this thoughtful of business
and marketing back, like,
you know what I mean?
Everyone's mixing.
Like there's so much smarter shit going on
I think I think you guys are so creative
like I think one of the things
you might want to think about
format wise,
is doing a show in a ratchet club
where you mix up the content
where it's not just you
and I think you and Dave Chappelle
would fucking kill together
like that would be like headline shit
but like, I think there's a format that
you might be able to
fuckin' invent or play with.
that I think is unique to
you because your permission
just because the way you're rolling.
Like the Revolt conference,
that Diddy just did down in Atlanta
you know they're good panels
and people talking real thoughtful shit
or Complex Con.
Like that thing, mixed with entertainment.
There's something, I see it.
I just think you need to mix
into other entertainment pots.
When I saw the Fallon
thing I'm like, good, good.
I'm like just like it's there for you.
- [Man] I think a podcast
would be easy for all you guys.
Like, a baby podcast with
like you, Chop, Tee Gee Kid,
all four or five of y'all.
- [Da Baby] With just a topic?
- [Man] Y'all would just bullshit.
- [Da Baby] Right.
(mumbling)
And then when you're like on tour
and you just you bring on one guest
like somebody that you're pop with
or you want a feature on
or you guys fuck with comes through.
- [Man] I mean they talk shit nonstop.
- To each other?
- [Man] To each other.
- Yeah of course.
- [Man] Yeah but I mean
it's entertaining as hell.
- Of course it is.
Like family (chains drown out
speaker) always entertaining.
- He suggested that we all
need to put one of these on
and shit.
(crosstalk)
- My man, on some real shit,
you need to have a surgery
and fucking implant
that shit into yourself
- I be a lot more open to it
and I ain't living the wrong way no more
so we don't, it don't matter anyways.
- Honestly even--
Like honestly, you know, man.
Yep you're right you're not and that's it
- Alright for sure.
So like what if every time we do do it
like I did last night when
we was out on Time Square
in front of the billboard,
we plug up I put in the Lapel on
so you would here people natural
you know their natural conversation.
- You need to have it on as
often as fucking possible 100%
I went like a fucking year and a half
of having it on 15 hours a day.
We really went hard.
- [Da Baby] This type of
conversation I ain't giving that up
and I ain't ready to.
- You don't want them to have the secrets.
You need to execute them first.
- [Da Baby] I mean I have
them if they still, you know
guess it ain't shit
that you not giving out
on a daily basis anyway
- 100%.
The funniest shit about my life
is I'm literally giving it away.
Like $0.00.
People fucking talk but people don't do.
Everyone's gonna be a billionaire
that's cool and then people
sitting in the fucking room
playing 2k.
It's about the quickest way
not to get to be a millionaire
unless you're the best
2k player in the world
and winning titles.
You know?
People just talk.
You have humility.
People don't see it.
People see the bravado
but doing those shows,
you know any people hit
like the way you just hit
and stop doing the shows
that you're still doing?
- [Da Baby] Everybody.
- I know.
I do the same thing, I'm still doing it.
'Cause I'm more comfortable in the dirt.
There's nothing else to say.
There's nothing else to
say some second tier,
third tier of school in Philly suburb
that's fucking exactly right.
Means you booked it a while ago
and you're gonna fucking
do your obligation.
It means that, fuck it
we're driving through anyway
I'm gonna take the bag,
means you like what you fucking do.
People don't like to perform,
no wonder their fucking
backing out of shit
and not doing it.
They aren't actually good and or like it.
I get paid fucking
$200,000 to give a speech
and it's a waste of my time
and I still do it because
I fucking love it.
And I'm not confused
that that's more money
than I made the first seven
years of my career, in one day.
So that will never get away from me
because exactly where I came from.
But it's still not the right move for me
but I do it 'cause I like it.
(Hip Hop music)